being like in blast position and being
such a staple in la hip-hop for a long
time that maybe wasn't you know like i
said he was kind of
you know la's best kept secret for a
long time i can only imagine
um does it have you guys ran into
old blast [ __ ] people trying to put it
out like hey yo we did this in 2016.
yeah every week
so how do you deal with that
do you like let do you let let [ __ ] fly
or do you say hey look man times are
different now nah i mean me i think
the whole point of having a manager in
the first place is so as an artist you
don't have to have those awkward
conversations like sometimes if you got
a personal relationship with the person
then yeah you're gonna have to have that
conversation on your own sometimes
because they're gonna come directly to
you because they probably got your
number or being right but for the most
part it's me having a conversation it's
like
hey my music and it's like it's not it's
not like it's disrespect it's just more
so like what we doing with the culture
that we build in the timeline that we
just doesn't line up yeah just don't
line up
i say all business has to be mutually
beneficial i've had uh
at least once or twice someone play me
blast records in the studio here
that like
are old yeah like yeah you know we've
just been holding this and i'm like good
luck yeah it's never coming out because
black i mean you know as all like super
peculiar artists are they like
i don't sound like that don't worry oh
100 every artist is like that right yeah
it's so crazy like but this [ __ ] is fire
and like that [ __ ] happens with my
artists all the time
we'll have a song that we love and it's
like a year old but man that [ __ ] is old
and it's like
but it's fire like just like you held on
to it too long yeah and so yeah we get
that every day i just had that
conversation yesterday with somebody